you know guys I'd really like to focus
on the positive for just a minute here
jussie Smollett is catching a lot of
flak for for what he did staging a hate
crime but here's the thing he did create
two jobs at way above minimum wage I
mean he paid 3500 bucks for just you
know less than an hour's work and and
that's uh that's a lot better than Alex
Danji occasional Cortes has done so far
in Congress I mean she lost her city
25,000 jobs so Smollett by comparison is
an expert job creator he has created
25,000 and 2 more jobs than Alexandra
occasional Cortes have so so that's
that's one thing that all that I'll say
for and that's gotta count for something
and let's focus on let's focus actually
on another positive thing here for for a
minute we live despite what you may have
heard despite what is advertised we live
in the least racist least sexist least
homophobic most tolerant most accepting
most open-minded civilization ever to
exist on planet Earth and it's not even
close that's the truth now we aren't
perfect I would never say that and I
would say as a pro-lifer that our
acceptance and our tolerance and our
very welcoming attitude stops
unfortunately at the womb which is a
massive oversight which has led to the
death of 60 million human beings and
Counting but speaking of issues about of
race and in gender and sexuality
specifically when it comes to that kind
of thing we are without question the
most tolerant civilization ever period
now that doesn't mean that racism and
sexism don't exist
nobody's claiming that there is racism
and sexism in this country but it does
mean that we in modern civilization
modern Western civilization I should say
have come as close to a
Radek ating those things racism and
sexism as anyone ever has which is
pretty impressive
and it means that no matter your race or
your gender or your sexual orientation
you can be as successful in this country
as your ambition and your intelligence
and your your skill will will take you
and it doesn't work that way in every
country in the world and there was a
time when it didn't work that way in
this country because it didn't work that
way anywhere but it does now and it does
here and that's pretty incredible that
that's something that we should be
grateful for doesn't mean we stop
working to make things even better but
but why not stop and have a little bit
of gratitude huh why not stop and say
wow I mean we really are fortunate to
live here because the fact is I don't
care who you are
I don't care who you are I don't care
what your race is what your gender is
what you know I don't care one of the 57
different genders you belong to if you
could be born in any time and any place
you would choose right here right now
you would not want to go anywhere else
in the world at any other point in
history that's a fact and so that's
something isn't it
isn't that something but what we find is
that and this is what gets me is that on
the left they they just there is no
gratitude and there's I think there's
little gratitude anywhere else that
gratitude is something that's sorely
missing in our society I know that it's
even missing from from you know I need
to work on being more grateful I think
we all need to work on it but the
problem on the Left what you find is
that we live in the most tolerant and
open civilization in the history of the
world but they seek validation and
identity in oppression and so for them
it's like unfortunate it's not just that
they lack gratitude it's that they
actively win
Shh that it were that it were otherwise
and the rash of fake hate crimes to
include smo let's shows how desperate
the victimhood mongers have become we
can think about some aloud from it he's
a gay black man who is successful or was
anyway effort eat before he destroyed
his career now a millionaire a gay black
man is a who's a millionaire making tens
of thousands of dollars per episode to
do his show which wasn't enough for him
which is why apparently one of the
reasons why he staged a hate crime so
someone who in other parts of the world
that would face possibly violent
persecution and at other points in
history in our own country would have
now is is you know a millionaire
successful living in this in this you
know a nice part of this city in an in a
nice fancy high-rise and he was so
to be persecuted that he could go ahead
to hire people to do it for him
he wasn't yeah apparently that was a job
we always heard about immigrants doing
jobs that Americans aren't willing to do
well oppressing Jessie Smollett
apparently is a job that no American was
willing to actually do so he had to go
hire someone to do it but it's not just
this I mean think about think just think
about other recent events just from the
last few weeks we had the coveted
Catholic thing the media spun this
dramatic yarn about Catholic students
randomly accosting in an innocent Native
American man and then this week on
Twitter like we talked about
they leftist dusted off an old a 50-year
old interview with John Wayne and spent
the day scolding his corpse and then
just a couple days ago feminists as I
mentioned on the show as well feminists
got very upset because the director of
the upcoming Ghostbusters movie said
that he wanted to give the movie back to
the fans which apparently is hurtful to
women for some reason or another and
then there were stories I saw yesterday
of the vagina monologues being cancelled
at various colleges because apparently
it's now offensive to transgenders to
have the Vagina Monologues because it
excludes you know because it insinuates
that you have to have a vagina to be a
woman god forbid the point is that the
left apparently now has to dig up the
dead or hire Nigerians if they want to
be oppressed they are reduced to
searching for oppression in Ghostbusters
movies and in The Vagina Monologues they
find martyrdom now in a facial
expression think about all the all of
the the think pieces that were written
about the the the smirk of the innocent
Covington Catholic student oh yeah he
didn't do anything but look at that
smirk I'm traumatized by the smirk by
that by that the way that he smiles
because they can't just admit that we
are the least racist least sexist least
homophobic most open-minded and
welcoming society ever to exist aren't
they can't accept that they can't admit
it
rather than express gratitude for the
unearned privilege of living in by far
the most accepting time and place
imaginable they go around turning over
every rock looking into every crevice
with a flashlight searching desperately
to find the faintest hint of something
that they might construe as bigotry and
if they can't find it then they just
invent it so what we've achieved in this
country this unprecedented level of
tolerance and acceptance which is
supposedly the very thing that these
people are fighting for it's being
squandered it's being wasted on a
generation of people who spend their
whole lives convincing themselves that
their persecuted and that is the great
shame that after after in in this
civilization after we climbed out of the
muck of bigotry and racism and slavery
and all of that climbed out of that
built this on this tolerant civilization
and yet it's being wasted on people who
do not appreciate it on a related note
Democratic presidential candidates are
coming out now in favor of reparations
so this is happening folks this is
really happening reparations is becoming
a mainstream Democratic talking point
both Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris
have expressed their support for the
idea of reparations which is the idea of
giving payments to black Americans
because of slavery a payment that would
have to come from white Americans now as
I said before Warren and Harris have
have endorsed this idea here is Harris
on a radio show called The Breakfast
Club making her case for reparations
well look I think that we have got to
address that again it's back to the
inequities there it through you know
look
America has a history of 200 years of
slavery we had Jim Crow we had legal
segregation in America we've got to
recognize back to that earlier point
people aren't starting out on the same
base in terms of their ability to
succeed and so we have got to recognize
that and give people the lift up now
this is obviously a crazy idea for a
whole host of reasons I don't even know
where to begin with it but first of all
a large percentage of black Americans in
this country now are not descended from
slaves because people immigrated here
from from from Africa every year
thousands of people come here from from
Africa so there's a large percentage of
black Americans who came to this country
after slavery had already been abolished
second a large percentage a very large
percentage of white people are not only
not descended from slave owners but
their ancestors weren't even in the
country during the slavery era my
ancestors were dying of the potato
famine while slavery was happening here
in America so it doesn't make any it's
to kind of break this down white people
versus black people and say well the
white people have to play play pay the
black people for for slavery doesn't
make any sense third even if you even if
you limited reparations to only those
black Americans who are descended from
slaves and you took money only from
those white Americans whose families
lived here during slave times which
isn't how it would work or could work
but even if it did work that way it
would still be incredibly unjust because
you're punishing people for the sins of
long dead relatives and you're rewarding
other people for hardships that they
themselves did not experience now if
this was 1860 and we were talking about
reparations then I would stay ok yeah
but it's not it's it's 2019 it's 150
years later 4th thing live
love to talk about spectrums right
gender is a spectrum everything's a
spectrum
well oppression and privilege is also a
spectrum right they this that also
exists you have oppression over here and
privilege over here and there's a
there's a spectrum as you get closer to
to privilege slavery was a unique horror
but it's not the only form of oppression
it was worse in degree from other forms
but it's not alone in the category of
oppression so if we're giving people
payments for historical persecution then
what about Native Americans what about
women who couldn't even vote in this
country until 100 years ago what about
the Japanese who were sent to internment
camps what about any other ethnic or
racial minority that experienced
prejudice what about the Irish who are
persecuted in their home country and
then came here and were discriminated
against when they got here if you think
the Irish have had it easy historically
that I would encourage you to pick up a
book and read it
the point is it's actually not easy to
find people in America whose ancestors
did not suffer some form of persecution
or discrimination that's it's it's very
difficult to do I mean arguably most I
would even say arguably most people can
say that they belong to a category that
at one point in America and certainly
elsewhere in the world was a you know
discriminated against so you really
really you pretty much have to limit
yourself to white male Protestant
anglo-saxons that's that's probably the
only group you can find that has not
been widely and historically
discriminated against in America now and
that's
not because America was uniquely racist
or uniquely prejudiced it was for a
while simply non uniquely prejudiced for
a very long time the entire world was
tribalistic discriminatory suspicious of
outsiders and so on that's that's the
way human civilization works for
thousands of years but if we're doing
reparations I don't see how you can
ignore those other groups I think they
should get something too shouldn't they
and certainly to make them pay
reparations would be severely unjust so
the whole idea of course is crazy I mean
there's this I hesitate to say this
because every time I think things can't
get any Dumber they do but it seems to
me that there's no way that this could
actually become a policy because it's
such it's such a wildly unpopular and
insane idea but the fact look the fact
that you've got it so far and I'm sure
others will join the jump on the
bandwagon but so far you have two
Democratic presidential candidates
including
the one who a lot of people think is the
favorite Kamala Harris who are coming
out in favor of this idea I mean that
just shows you how far left and crazy
extremist wacko the Democratic Party has
become Barack Obama was the most liberal
president we had ever had and he was
also as you remember still is a black
man but even he he didn't he was not in
favor of reparation this subject came up
a couple of times and and he did not
endorse the idea so and that was not
that long ago so there is this the
Democratic Party is running running left
very rapidly and this is just another
symptom of that here's one more symptom
by the way I've been meaning to mention
this maybe you saw this but speaking of
crazy leftist stuff
the transgender actor India Moore who's
a biological male
who claims to be a female and apparently
is the star of some show called pose I
think on maybe FX or somewhere anyway he
he said out of tweet a couple days ago
which I got a pretty big reaction the
tweet said if a woman has a penis her
penis is a biologically female penis
yeah it may be the most concerning thing
about that tweet is the last I saw it it
had like five thousand it had several
thousand likes people that were agreeing
with it if a woman has a penis for penis
as a biological female is that that's
that is exactly like saying it for
square is a circle it's a circular
square it just it it is a it's a total
non sequitur it makes absolutely no
sense and of course when you're using a
phrase like biologically female penis
then you have just the term biologically
female now has no meaning what does the
what does the term biologically female
mean if you can have a biologically
female male pop apart it just it doesn't
mean anything it we have we've just got
rid of it now I bring this up for two
reasons number one it's just a it's it's
more evidence of of how crazy left the
left has gotten but number two if it's
important to keep up with with this to
understand what the argument is so you
know what you're arguing against and
there was a time not that long ago when
the left would they would they would
acknowledge that there's at least a
distinction between biological sex and
gender or I should say I said they would
acknowledge the distinction i I mean
they invented a distinction between
something between this thing called
gender and sex and so but but they were
at least for a while maintaining that
there is something called biological sex
there is a certain reality to it
but what they argued is that gender is
this other thing that can override
biological sex that was the argument for
a long time now that's gone now they're
saying no biological sex is not a thing
doesn't exist there there is if if a man
decides that he's a woman then he is now
a biologically female woman his
biological sex is now female because of
his because he desires to be female so
by the force of his own will and his own
desire he can now literally change his
biology that is the argument that the
left makes and of course it should go
without saying that if you make that
argument or if you agree with that
argument you lose the right to even say
the word science from now on and you
certainly cannot go around accusing
anyone else of being anti science
because this is the very definition of
anti science this is this is what it
means to be anti science alright so
we've got a bunch of emails I want to
get to actually actually hold on before
we get to the emails I had something
else said one other thing I wanted to
talk to you about a very important thing
actually so I wanted to talk about soap
for a minute
I was thinking about this last night
because these are the kinds of things I
think about you see when I was a single
man I had two different types of soap in
my apartment only two I had bath
soap and I had kitchen soap and that's
all and whatever needed to be cleaned in
the kitchen I would use the kitchen soap
for that and whatever needed to be
cleaned in the bathroom I would use the
bathroom soap for that and if I ran out
of bathroom soap I would take my kitchen
soap and I would bring it to the
bathroom and I would use it as bathroom
soap you know why because it's just soap
soap is soap all soap is basically the
same but then I got married and now I
have 14 different kinds of soap just in
my shower and masses of different soaps
on the bathroom counter and soaps of all
sizes and consistencies and some soap
even that is just there for decoration
so there is soap to be used and soap to
be viewed and soap for each individual
body part I have three soap dispensers
by my kitchen sink there are even
different kinds of soap for the laundry
and there's just soap everywhere we
spend 19 thousand dollars a month
literally on soap and why why do we do
this
all soap as I said is the same I've got
news for you you could bathe with
laundry detergent and you'd be fine okay
it that that's that's when I was a kid
we we took baths with laundry detergent
we walked to school uphill both ways
it's just out of control as my only
point and if you add that to as I've
already discussed my wife's pillow
addiction it's just all the blankets
everywhere all the pillows and the
candles and the soap and I'll tell you
this that if we were on the Oregon Trail
or something we would be screwed because
we need a whole new sweet hope we need
we need a whole separate wagon just for
the soap and we need a separate pack
mule just for the blankets and the
pillows and this is this is why we can't
go on road trips anymore because we've
done road trips 87% of our luggage
consists of various soft fluffy things
do you don't have any soft fluffy things
I bring with me if I'm traveling alone
none and I don't bring any soap either
do you know why because wherever
I'm going in modern civilization they're
gonna have that stuff when I get there
so my point simply is I'm not sure what
my point is I'm just complaining but
also I want to say that that ladies I
think far be it for me to suggest this
but I think you could maybe condense
things down a little bit a little bit of
efficiency here so here's my suggestion
okay to all women
choose four soaps that you like for the
whole house you get four soaps now all
you really need is one two is two is
extravagant but I'll give you 4 choose 2
pillows and two blankets and and that's
all you need you don't need any more
than that and just and you can donate
the rest to charity or whatever sure you
know whatever you want to do with it all
right
now that I've gotten that off my back
I'm gonna get to some of your emails mat
wall show at gmail.com mat wall show at
gmail.com is the email there's a lot of
interesting emails as well I wanted to
give it some extra time so this is from
Albert it says hi mat Albert here love
your show I listen all the way from
Africa I've heard you speak twice about
class classroom situations involving
students disrespecting teachers such as
that young man who was assaulted and the
one who was recently arrested as a
teacher myself I'm very appreciative of
how well you understand our situations
and what we have to deal with you're
always spot on in your analyses of the
classroom incidents well hi Albert and
thank you for lit for listening all the
way from Africa and thank you for that
comment you know I'm sometimes accused
of hating teachers or you know being
against teachers or whatever but nothing
could be further from the truth I'm I'm
a I'm a big critic of the public school
system here in America and I'm a critic
of the teachers union and I do believe
that there are some really bad teachers
out there who unfortunately become like
these educational parasites that you
can't get rid of mainly because of the
unions so I do believe that but there
are also a lot of very good teachers and
I fully realized and I've said many
times as you allude to that teachers
these days are put in a really
impossible situation and we need to
appreciate that
because they have to deal with these out
of control you have to deal with these
out-of-control kids kids who've had no
discipline or respect or anything
instilled in them at home and and then
the teachers are tasked with trying to
trying to teach in spite of that and to
make matters worse whenever one of these
out-of-control kids gets really out of
control and becomes an intolerable
distraction in an educational
environment when out whatever the
teacher then does to deal with that
situation to address the problem will be
opposed by the bad kids bad parents who
refuse to believe that their precious
little child is actually an enormous
Brett or worse and so you know I think
about that and to think about my own
experience in school and I have a lot of
respect for and sympathy for the good
teachers who are who are burdened with
dealing with with I I certainly wouldn't
want to deal with it so thanks again
this is from Nathan he says Matt Anthony
asked a question about God and suffering
last episode but you kind of skipped
over the part of the question I really
wanted to hear your opinion on you led
with I paraphrase how can God have a
plan for us while also allowing us
freedom of choice I've wondered this a
lot as a Catholic and I can't come up
with an answer on my own it seems to me
silly for God to have a plan for us
seeing as he allows us free choice it
also knows all the choices we'll make
doesn't doesn't really fit with the
definition of a plan if he has of course
he wants us to take it seems like that
would involve violating our free will
which kind of violates a lot of
theological ideas for example people
often say as I used to say that it was
God's plan that I ended up with my wife
but everything that led to our meeting
could have changed if I made a different
choice is it possible for God to lead us
to a certain thing without violating our
ability to freely choose thanks for your
input and God bless you're right yeah
not even mention I did skip over that
because Anthony asked there was an email
last yesterday
talking about I guess there was this
question and then also about the problem
of suffering and you know how can God
allow suffering so I kind of focused on
that element and not on this so this
obviously is a classic question as well
and it's a classic challenge to
believers if if God knows what we are
going to do how do we have the choice to
do anything else other than what he
knows we're going to do anything anyway
if we do something other than what he
knew we do doesn't that mean that he
isn't omniscient but if we can't do
anything else doesn't that mean we
aren't free and so we don't have free
will now I actually think that the more
serious and the more difficult challenge
Nathan
even isn't related to God's knowledge of
our actions but actually it's related to
God's knowledge of his own actions so a
popular atheist argument is that the the
Christian conception of God is a logical
contradiction that's a logical
contradiction they say because if God is
omnipotent then he can do anything if
he's omniscient then he knows everything
but if he knows everything if he knows
everything then he knows what he himself
is going to do in the future but if he
knows what he's going to do in the
future that he can't do anything else
other than what he knew he was going to
do and if he did something else and that
we mean what that would mean that that
that he's not omniscient but if he
couldn't do anything else other than
what he knew he was going to do then
that would mean that he's not omnipotent
so it's the same kind of kind of
challenge but I think framed in a way
that's even more well challenging I
guess the answer to both though I think
is the same and it has to do with the
nature of time so there's there's a
problem in the way that we talked about
this question because our premise is
flawed we say that God knows we this is
the way we put it we say well God knows
what we are going to do or what he is
going to do but that assumes you're
you're talking
in in a in the context of a future that
that assumes that there is a future for
God and assuming there's a future
assumes that he exists in time so it
assumes that he is in time and he knows
what I'm going to do tomorrow because he
can he could he can look sort of into
the future like he's looking into a
crystal ball and see it but that's
incorrect time is a dimension of reality
time itself has a beginning everybody
agrees with that even atheists agree
that time we haven't always had time it
is possible to be outside of time
because time has a beginning and the
creator of time God obviously has to be
outside of it because he created it so
what that means is it's not that he
knows what will happen it's it's that he
knows what is happening everything is
now for him he it is in eternal now
right so remember that the the Christian
conception of God also includes
changelessness we say that God is
changeless and to be changeless means
that you have to exist outside of time
because time is an agent of change time
is potentiality so I am in time and that
means that there's always a but that you
know there's potential like I could do
this I could do that
I'm always becoming something when
you're in time you're always in a state
of flux a state of change a state of
becoming but God has no potentiality God
his only actuality he is actuality
itself he is the ground of all being
this is kind of like the philosophical
idea of God that's been developed
through Christian thought God is the I
am right he is the he is he is existence
the now so he doesn't see the future he
sees the now and all is now another way
of looking at that is if I had a okay so
to use a prop so I have this mini cigar
sometimes I smoke the mini ones because
the bigger ones take forever anyway so
you have this it says mini cigars so
basic
like you look at something like this
right and if this is my life if my if
this little thing cigar here's my life
then if you're listening on iTunes you
can't really see that but so I have to
experience this right like along this so
I start here this is my birth and then I
go here to here to here and so I'm
experiencing my life sequentially one
moment at a time and I get to the end of
my life which is the other end here and
and then I die but and I could only see
my life one little centimeter at a time
right but God can look at this and he
sees the entire thing all at once
he's not watching it happen inch by inch
he sees the entire thing like he's this
is my life he sees it
so obviously the whole idea of someone
existing outside of time we we can't
wrap our head around that we can't fully
conceive of what that means but we know
that is the case for God and so that
does that is the way of sort of dealing
with this challenge of God knowing what
we're going to do as for your point
about God not planning your marriage to
your wife I agree with that I have said
that you know my wife and I were not
faded in the stars we were not destined
to be together I could have married
someone else she could have she could
have said no to me when when when I
proposed she could have left me at the
altar and frankly maybe she should have
she probably could have done better
honestly but but she didn't and so we
had this choice and this is why at least
in the Catholic right I'm not sure about
other churches but I know that when I
got married one of the first questions
that we were asked by the priest is are
are you here of your own free will and
volition and and the point is that um it
has to be your choice it has to be
freewill and if you're not there of your
own free will and volition then it's not
a valid marriage a marriage cannot occur
unless you choose it the sacrament of
marriage is bestowed by the spouses on
to each other
through their own choice and that's what
makes it so exciting and beautiful and
wonderful and romantic and terrifying is
that is that it wasn't meant to be it
was a choice that you made it is a it is
a choice it was one of a million other
choices you could have made yet you made
that choice and now now through that
choice you are meant to be now you
weren't before
when I met my wife first for a second I
met her I thought wow she's beautiful
but but no love at first sight how can I
say I loved her I didn't know her you
know it's if love is a choice
marriage is a choice and once you make
that choice of marriage now you're meant
to be until you die
so what does it mean for God to have a
plan for us yet for us to have free will
at the same time I think it just means
that God is is the ground of being of
existence he holds us all into existence
providing the context for our choices
consenting to everything that occurs
which isn't to say that he that he that
he makes the choices for us but every
second that we exist he is allowing us
to exist and ultimately he works all
things to his greater glory but but but
he chooses to work with the material
with the raw material of our choices I
hopefully that answered the question
sort of
let's see what else from Aaron he says
why did you stop doing your podcast in
your car I'm sure I'm not the first one
to ask you this and I'm not quite sure
why you haven't addressed it but I will
send you this question every day until
you answer it so you might as well do it
now well Aaron with that kind of thread
suppose I have to answer and the answer
is that I stopped doing the shows of my
car because my car is in the shop let's
do uh let's do one more email let's see
from Tammy says your shows brilliant I'm
going to copy your tattoo anyway go for
it it's not it's not trademark Matt in
yesterday's show an email or mentioned
that Democrats should be protecting the
unborn because of their victim status
the main reason why they don't care
about unborn the unborn status as a
victim is because they don't vote the
unborn don't vote
I promise you the only way Dems will
care as if damn if if Dems could somehow
win votes from the unborn I think it's
very good point and I'll read one more
from Syria says hi Matt I'm a
stay-at-home mom of four children I love
your podcast don't agree with everything
you say but appreciate being challenged
by your point of view you've said some
very interesting things really make me
think I want to address your perspective
on this drag queen story Eller as a
Christian mom I am personally disgusted
by this recent development you had
mentioned a point I had never considered
and that was that drag queens tend to
dress as over sexualized versions of my
gender got me to thinking that if a drag
queen really wanted to represent the
female gender they would dawn yoga pants
a pink graphic tee that says will work
for tacos and put his hair in a messy
top knot or messy bun I personally don't
dress this way because I love my husband
and children believe I should take a
little more care with my appearance for
their sake since they have to look at me
but the majority of my demographic has
reverted to the style preference mostly
out of humor and convenience anyway just
thought you made an excellent point I
myself a concern about the long term
effect of these new cultural norms what
they will have my children yeah I think
that's it's a good point and that's and
that's that's the thing and that's why
you know that's why minstrel shows or so
in blackface is so racist and horrible
because it reduces someone's identity to
a stick basically and and to a costume
and a stick and and that's the same
thing that drag queens do and drag shows
and everything it's it's taking the
female identity and making it into a
cartoon making it into a stick into a
costume and of course that is a
degrading demeaning cheapening sort of
thing so that was an excellent point
thank you for emailing thank you ever
want everyone for watching and talk to
you next week have a great weekend
Godspeed